هذه اثار الضمار التي خلفها قصف مخبز في
ليسيتش انسك المدينه الواقعه في منطقه
لوغانسك سقطت في ايدي القوات الروسيه في
صيف
2022 بعد معركه عنيفه موسكو اتهمت الجيش
الاوكراني بتنفيذ هذه الضربه التي خلفت
العديد من القتلى من بينهم مسؤولون
روس لا يمكن ان يوصف ما وقع الا بالعمل
الارهابي ان استمرار الهجمات على البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه كاسته في هذا المخبز هو
عمل ارهابي وحشي عدد الضحايا يشير الى
فداحه هذا العمل الارهابي العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه مستمره لضمان عدم وقوع
المزيد من الاعمال
الارهابيه العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
مستمره في مدينه خيرسون مسؤولون اوكرانيون
محليون اكدوا مقتل العديد من المدنيين في
هجوم بالمدفعيه الروسيه كما قالوا الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي اشاد من جهته
بقدره قواته على ضرب القوات الروسيه بعيدا
عن ساحه المعركه في البر والبحر على
السواء كما قال خلال زيارته ساحه تدريب
عسكريه في منطقه
دنيبرو اريد ان اشكركم على تدمير الاهداف
الجويه للعدو شكرا لكم للدفاع عن بلدنا
والدفاع عن عائلاتنا والدفاع عن
اوكرانيا اوكرانيا اعلنت انها دمرت سفينه
حربيه روسيه قباله سواحل جزيره القر كما
انها تستهدف الاراضي الروسيه بانتظام
بضربات وهجمات بطائرات
مسيره